[Music]
all right anthony lynn talking about the
quarterback competition in l.a tyrod
taylor probably will be our day one
starter justin herbert the sixth overall
pick and a rookie out of oregon has to
got to be ready to play this is a year
of a lot of uncertainty every player has
to prepare and be ready to start
him sitting out the whole year that may
not be the case so we expect to see
justin herbert at some point this year
although tyrod taylor now has the best
group around him i think he's ever had
justin herbert a candidate for offensive
rookie of the year if he plays a
significant chunk of the season so let's
draft the offensive rookie of the year
candidates for 2020 chris since i'm in
such a good mood today although
circumstance is doing their best to
interfere with that i'm gonna let you
have the first wow thanks there slugger
what a good guy you are okay it's friday
for you i'm giving you a little friday
nugget on the way out the door i'll take
it i'll take it i'm gonna start off with
the guy we kind of started off talking
on the show with today i mean yeah clyde
edwards elaire is the guy that jumps out
to me there's no doubt i mean one i
thought he was the best running back
coming out in the draft he's super
talented and then when super talented
meshes up with whoa system fit and then
other super talented guys around you i
just go well like the only thing we have
to worry about is like can they give
them the ball enough times because they
got so many damn good players but i
expect it to be
i'm going on a limb and just gonna go i
expect it to be better than kareem hunt
and what we saw his rook his rookie year
for the kansas city chiefs i think yeah
so i'm putting i'm putting myself out
there i think it's gonna be a huge year
for this guy
well and you throw in the damian
williams opt out which is the reason why
we're doing this draft today it creates
an even greater opportunity for clyde
edwards hillary and that's always the
first place i look for offensive rookie
of the year i look at running back
because running back has the if you if
you are the guy and not every guy gets
to be the guy right out of the gates but
if you are going to get a healthy
compliment of touches you're more likely
to generate the kind of statistics
touchdowns notoriety fantasy football
love that's going to get those 50 ap
voters attracted to you and it almost
happened last year with josh jacobs the
raiders running back he you know a lot
of people still think he should have
been the offensive rookie of the year
over kyler murray and i generally think
a running back has a better opportunity
and i would have taken clyde edwards
hillary if i had kept the first pick for
myself so
i'm a little torn here but i'm not going
to let you have joe burrow and clyde
edwards hilaire although i was tempted
to go in a different direction i got to
go with joe burrow first overall pick we
saw what kyler murray did last year as
the first overall pick it's going to be
a challenge in cincinnati because of the
division that they play in
but i think that if joe burrow can carry
over just 80 percent of what he did at
lsu last year it's going to create
enough buzz
enough excitement he's got the help
around him if those guys can stay
healthy that would be a great group of
receivers if they can stay healthy joe
mixon sneaky great running back who
hasn't had the benefit of a whole lot of
blocking or a passing game to throw
defenses off balance that's right that
cincinnati bengals offense could be
something i don't know about the defense
but i think the offense could be
something no i i'm with you you're right
i mean they they could be one of those
teams that ends up like six and ten but
we go man like the 49ers a few years ago
where we go it was fun to watch every
game it was up and down the field and
big plays and everything like that and i
think you know like you said there's
enough talent there and with the way he
plays and and the plays he can make on
his own too uh i i it was it was one of
those two guys for me too and you know
i'm not one that usually wants to take
the first pick of the draft for these
kind of things but i i think it sets up
well for him man there are some really
good guys out here to talk about
all right i'm i think um
next i'm going to go with brandon nyuk
of the san francisco 49ers you know and
the reason i'm going to go with this
here is
debo samuel hurt broken foot here the
last few weeks don't think he'll be
ready to go or at least not full
strength hundred percent to start the
year you know there's no emanuel sanders
there
and of course we know shanahan john
lynch liked this player a lot kyle's got
a a keen eye for the wide receiver
position you know he's really special
there and i just think between the
player his offense
it's going to fit within his scheme and
of course with no debo and samuels there
i think there's a lot of balls that are
going to go ix way you know especially
early in the year at least to get him
going while debo might be still getting
his feet underneath him so i'm going to
go with him just because of that offense
a team around him and he's not a guy
that they're necessarily going to be
able to hone in on because there's a lot
of talent on that offense and uh i think
shanahan's gonna make life pretty easy
for him
yeah i don't know the team that went
with the early 70s offense uh when it
could last year in the playoffs running
the ball running and running the ball
and my other concern is
who's the guy that's going to draw the
double coverage i know
that makes it easier for brandon area to
get open
gonna be a kittle kittle have to be the
guy that shanahan yeah you don't get
double cover coverage on a tight end a
lot so i know what you're saying but
it'll have to be shanahan who will have
a million plays for george kittle at
least to take a little attention away
from a guy like oyuk which is a very
real question mike no doubt
well and i raised those questions for
two reasons number one i want to
undermine your pick of course i want to
build up my pick because he's not a b
he's cd cd lamb the dallas cowboys
receiver who has amari cooper there
to attract double coverage has the
running game that is the great
complement to the passing game with the
quarterback in dak prescott who you put
much higher on your
top 40 list than jimmy garoppolo mike
mccarthy is the head coach dialing up
those plays that give cd lamb the
opportunity with a high profile team to
come in and make a high profile splash
you throw in that extra factor where
he's going to have the chip on his
shoulder because he was drafted after
the alabama receivers henry ruggs iii
and jerry judy i think this is all
shaping up for cd lamb to have a monster
season barring injury yeah i think he
could come in and be great and and the
star on the helmet's going to get more
attention you know if he has the same
production as brandon nyuk the same
catches the same yards the same
touchdowns
cd lam's going to be viewed as having
the bigger year because he's coming from
that team that that that everything is
bigger no i mean listen i was between
ayuk and cd lamb that's what i was doing
i went with ayuk because of the reasons
that you just said for cd lab you know i
went with ayu because i'm going shanahan
even though there might be attention on
him there's not enough guys on that
offense he'll get him the ball
shanahan's a master at getting the julio
jones the andre johnsons of the world
the ball but everybody knows they're
going to get the ball so that's why i
went that's what scared me off a cd lamb
like you're right it to me can go either
way it can go whoa holy cow look at the
stats all over the place but it also
could go damn amari cooper damn ezekiel
elliott runs the ball damn michael
gallup had 1100 yards receiving last
year and that would just scare me that
some of his touches get taken away so
i'm doing what you're doing i like your
pick but i also want to win the draft
and i'm just pointing out some negatives
about it
let me say this about your buddy kyle
shanahan too yeah
because i think that part of his genius
isn't just designing plays and getting
guys open
and cracking the code on the defense
i think now that he has his own team
i think we are going to
see and i don't know
i'm not saying that this is job number
one job number one is score more points
and win the game but i think that his
offense is set up in a way to prevent
one guy from becoming the superstar
who's going to command huge money sure
right so i i i i you know you're not
going to have a julio jones that's going
to hold out and want 23 million a year
with the 49ers i think the ball is going
to get spread around it is
no one's gonna have those gigantic
numbers so that's another reason why i i
was so you're going backwards just throw
one more negative thing on my pick
before i make my other pick i mean what
a church i'm trying to i'm trying to
praise your buddy okay from the
standpoint of not creating
a a giant
major star that yeah i hear you and all
the money all right let's take a break
we've got one round left chris gets to
regroup now that i've got him on his
heels we'll do round three of the
offensive rookie of the year draft right
after this on pfti
[Music]
all right as we continue with our draft
offensive rookie of the year candidate
chris you're on the clock all right i'm
going jonathan taylor
you know second round running back out
of wisconsin who was a first round
talent i mean stud i mean 230 pounds
runs 4-3 got the big blue wall because
they built a wall in indianapolis he's
going to have big holes so yeah i'm
going with jonathan taylor because he's
got a lot there to support him and then
of course i think he is a hell of a
football player
yeah you took my next pick although i've
got one that i think has just the same
chance to to make some noise and maybe
be the offensive rookie of the year how
about jkd i knew you're running back out
of ohio state yeah i know that his
touches will be minimized by the
presence of mark ingram and lamar
jackson's going to be running the ball a
lot on a designed basis but man that
that that was just a pick that that
cemented in i think a lot of people's
minds that the ravens are still going to
be a major factor even though they can't
win a playoff game jk dobbins is going
to be a guy who comes in and makes a
difference and transitions into that
lead running back role when mark ingram
moves on chris yeah i'm with you mike
and you know he might be the guy you're
right not a ton of yards and like a ton
of touches but a lot of long highlight
touchdown game changing type runs and
that could win you rookie of the year so
i could see jk dobbins doing that for
sure all right one more quick break when
we return a player who signed a big
contract in the offseason relatively
speaking uh has gone awol we'll tell you
who it is and when and if he's going to
show up when pfd live continues right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports